We have a very interesting new poll out
of Quinnipiac University about whether
Republicans want Donald Trump to remain
involved in American politics and in
Republican Party politics for the foreseeable
future. And the answer is yes, they do.
Yes, they do. Three quarters of Republicans want
Donald Trump to continue playing a prominent
role in the Republican Party. The poll showed
89 percent of Republicans opposed the conviction
of Donald Trump in his Senate second Senate
impeachment trial. 87 percent of Republicans
say Trump should be allowed to hold public
office in the future. Eighty nine percent of
Republicans believe Trump was not responsible for
inciting the violence that led to the January 6th
riots. And among all Americans polled, 55
percent oppose Trump. Republican returning to
public office. So this is a very important number
because we talked last week or the week before,
about 64 percent of Republicans saying if
Trump left the party and started his own party,
we would follow him. Nearly two thirds of the
Republican Party has such soft support for the
party or has simply accepted Donald Trump as the
sort of lord and savior deity head of the party
at this point that they would follow him out of
it. That's not so good for the Republican Party
as an institution, but it's certainly good if
you're Donald Trump and you want to control
the Republican Party or American politics going
forward. Now, we learn that although there are
some Republicans who would not leave
the Republican Party to follow Trump,
many of them do want Trump to continue
involved in American politics. Now,
one important caveat is that we know from our
conversation with David Shorr a few weeks ago
that Republicans who answer
the phone and talk to pollsters
are not necessarily representative of all
Republicans. And David Shorr believes that some
of the more Trump and Kuhnen conspiracy types may
be refusing to participate in polls. Of course,
pollsters try to and believe they have ways of
accounting and adjusting for that. But David
Shaw was skeptical that they really are great at
it. So that's something, something to understand.
But assuming these numbers are roughly accurate,
this is really bad for Republicans as a party.
They lost the presidential election by almost
eight million people. And at this point in time,
most of them want Trump to stay involved and two
thirds are even willing to leave the party. I
don't know how the math works out for them. And
what I mean by that is if you lose a national
election by eight million, in great part because
of the guy who's at the head of the party, Donald
Trump, failing on coronavirus, turning off so many
traditional Republicans, you lose by eight million
and then you want that guy to stay involved. And
if he leaves the party, you'll leave with him.
Those are not numbers that bode well for the
Republican Party in national elections. Now, at
the local level, it's a very different situation.
You can still, you know, the Trump factor in
extremely red areas that would never consider
voting for, for example, a Democratic senator.
It may in practice not have that big of an impact.
But for as long as Donald Trump is so prominent,
it looks really tough for the Republican Party to
win national elections. And I'm glad to have my
mind changed, but I don't see how the numbers
work out now as a matter of sort of following
the nature or the easy nature by which so many
Republican voters were bamboozled by Donald Trump.
They fell for the populist sounding rhetoric
back in 2015 and 2016. We've talked about that
many times. Yeah, they fell for it. And then Trump
didn't do it. But they still don't seem to realize
that Trump has done nothing for just your average
working class Republican beyond. Yes. Making them
really afraid of others that are going to do bad
things to you. China, undocumented immigrants,
Democrats, communists, Marxists, anarchists or
anarchists, as Donald Trump would call them,
yeah, he stoked fears for the average
working class Republican really well,
he told them lies about the things
he would do, said he would fix trade.
He didn't do it, said he would build a wall across
the entire U.S. Mexico border. He didn't do it,
said he would replace Obamacare with a
beautiful new health care plan, didn't do it.
So fear, false promises, a coalescing the
most hateful elements of the Republican Party.
But they still seem not to realize that
he did nothing for them economically the
way he claimed to do. And now, as we know, 40
percent of coronavirus deaths during the Trump
administration were unnecessary and avoidable.
So, of course, all of the numbers. Wow, how does
the Republican Party win national elections in
these circumstances? But the other question is
millions, tens of millions still don't realize
Trump didn't do any of the things he said he would
do for the working class. Do they care? Do they
not know? I'm not sure. I don't know the answer,
but if they never wake up to it, support for Trump
in the Republican Party is likely to continue